una ardilla está corriendo a 12 pies por
segundo para cruzar una calle necesita
correr 9 pies 9 pies para llegar al otro
lado cuánto tiempo le tomará a la
ardilla recorrer los 9 pies 29 pies
redondea a la centésima de segundo más
cercana ok
luego dice un coche está a 50 pies de la
ardilla manejando hacia ella a 50 pies
manejando hacia ella a una velocidad de
100 pies por segundo esto suena muy
emocionante luego pregunta cuánto tiempo
le tomará al carro recorrer los 50 pies
redondea a la centésima de segundo más
cercana bueno la pregunta es podrán la
ardilla alcanzar a cruzar la calle sin
ser atropellada por el coche guau sí que
es una pregunta emocionante sobre todo
para la ardilla verdad bueno vamos a
empezar con la ardilla a ver qué pasa
entonces aquí le voy a poner la ardilla
la ardilla y le voy a poner que la
ardilla debe recorrer 9 pies 9 pies
y es y lo que queremos saber es cuánto
tiempo le tomará recorrer esos nueve
pies o sea ya tenemos una distancia y
hay que pasarla a tiempo y aquí nos da
en la velocidad nos dice que corre a 12
pies por segundo que le tenemos que
hacer a estos 9 pies con respecto a la
velocidad dividir entre 12 o multiplicar
entre 12 bueno para pensarlo podemos ver
las unidades
aquí tenemos pies que queremos pasar a
segundos entonces al hacer la conversión
necesitamos multiplicar por una tasa que
nos cancele 10 o sea que pies quede en
el denominador y que en el numerador nos
dé segundos lo voy a poner en color rosa
aquí le voy a poner segundos segundos y
vamos a ver esta tasa que es nos da 12
pies por segundo y aquí necesitamos
segundos por pies entonces simplemente
tomamos el recíproco de este número
entonces 12 pies por segundo es lo mismo
que en un segundo se recorren 12 pies
entonces aquí le voy a poner que en un
segundo se recorran 12 pies
12 10 vale bueno con esta tasa ya
podemos hacer la conversión eso que nos
daría 10 se cancela con pies justo eso
fue la idea de usar esta tasa arriba nos
queda segundos y serían 9 entre 12
segundos 9 entre 12 segundos segundos y
eso cuánto es 9 y 12 son divisibles
entre 3
9 / 332 entre 13 es 4 nos queda tres
cuartos eso de ahí es igual a 0.75 0.75
segundos segundos muy bien entonces eso
lo que nos da es cuánto tarda la ardilla
cuánto tarda la ardilla en cruzar la
calle vale y ahora vamos con el coche
que lo voy a poner de color azul coche
vale entonces la situación es más o
menos la siguiente la ardilla está
intentando cruzar la calle y el coche
está manejando hacia ella hacia ella
vale y lo que queremos ver es si la
ardilla alcanza a cruzar antes de ser
atropellado bueno vamos a ver cuánto
tarda el coche el coche en llegar a la
ardilla entonces ahora el coche lo que
tiene que recorrer son 50 pies 50 pies y
una vez más debemos pasar estos pies a
segundos entonces hay que multiplicar
por una tasa que nos cancele pies y que
arriban los de segundos le voy a poner
aquí segundos segundos y esta tasa otra
vez la obtenemos a partir de la
velocidad
aquí tenemos 100 pies
segundo verdad entonces eso es lo mismo
a que en un segundo se recorran 100 pies
100 pies no estoy diciendo nada raro si
simplemente estoy tomando esta
información que ya nos dan pero está al
revés de cómo la necesitamos entonces
simplemente tomo el recíproco bueno
entonces aquí piense cancela con pies y
nos queda todo en segundos 50 entre 100
es un medio y un medio es 0.5 entonces
hay que redondear a la centésima es 0.5
0 segundos segundos segundos muy bien
entonces el coche tarda 0.5 segundos la
ardilla 0.75 segundos vamos a responder
la pregunta podrá la ardilla alcanzar a
cruzar la calle sin ser atropellada por
el coche pues veamos la ardilla tarda
medio segundo
perdón 0.75 segundos y el coche sólo
tarda medio segundo entonces el coche va
a llegar a la ardilla antes de que la
ardilla cruce la calle sin entonces
desafortunadamente para para la ardilla
la ardilla no va a alcanzar a cruzar la
calle sin ser atropellada por el coche
aquí le pongo no pobre ardilla